I'm Angela Bassett and I'm doing a
Google autocomplete interview is Angela
Bassett a vegan absolutely not
I have been on occasion I love a vegan
meal I love good fresh wholesome food so
I've gone vegan I've gone raw vegan I've
gone raw I've gone bacon so they have it
is Angela Bassett dad oh heavens with
you I hope not I hope not I hope not to
have a dead day or dead conversation oh
that relationship or anything um no very
much alive
but thanks okay let's see is Angela
Bassett a dota I am a Delta Force a
couple of years ago I was asked by the
Delta sorority to become an honorary
member
sometimes I feel a little behind you
know because as the Delta I didn't
pledge while in college but there were
no sororities on my campus you know at
Yale there were secret societies and I
was too busy doing my theater thing so
yes I'm an honorary Delta is angela
bassett from chicago I love chai tau a
lot of Southern culture Delta culture
people who migrated from the south up to
the north great pizza great jazz got to
film movie chiraq with Spike Lee in
Chicago loves Chicago but actually from
further south st. Petersburg Florida is
Angela Bassett in the Thriller video
with Sir Michael mm no I wasn't but I
did play his mom Katherine Jackson in
the Jacksons miniseries my agents at the
time didn't think that I should you know
be a part of this because it was all
this talk about Michael Jackson and they
would say things like wacko Jacko but
i as a little girl growing up loving the
Jacksons in st. Petersburg they were my
first concert they were my first album I
daydreamed about those guys every single
day with my girlfriend you know who are
you gonna marry who you gonna marry I'll
go to marry Marla I'm going to marry
Michael so no I wasn't in the Thriller
video but I did play there mom and
Michael when I met him did say you were
wonderful